let's bring in Michael Porter Jr the
Nuggets forward former Missouri star he
joins us now where are you this morning
Michael thanks for joining us what's
going on I'm in Colorado Colorado some
Phil in Denver I get to go home today so
I'm excited for that are you interested
in seeing the uncle drew movie
I can't wait those are those commercials
and those clips some of my favorite
clips I can't wait till it comes out
there is Shaq is great in it Reggie
Miller Chris Webber
Kyrie looks great as well Aaron Gordon
makes a nice appearance there as well so
maybe you can get in the sequel here
Michael hope it's like I said it's my
favorite little clips all right let me
ask you a couple of things here that as
you look back put us in that green room
there where you're just waiting for your
name to get called what's that feeling
like when you're just waiting yeah it's
a crazy feeling you know especially for
me because my my thing was a little
different I had no idea where I was
going so it was kind of weird know my
agent kind of knows all the teams so the
teams will call ahead and say if they
were they were going to draft me or not
so his team we're buying team whereby it
was kind of crazy but you know my whole
thing all along just getting just to the
right team and I feel like that happened
for me and out here in Denver I'm loving
it I'm loving my teammates and and
everything about it so I feel like this
is a perfect situation for me what's the
motive motivation I would think for you
Michael yeah no doubt you know most
people didn't expect me to go 14 but
that's alright I mean if you could draft
number one all you can do is prove
people right you know I mean like yeah I
you gotta perform and but be addressed
to the 14 I get prove everybody wrong so
that's that would be really fun and I
can't wait to do that were you ready to
go into the NBA right out of high school
no doubt that was before you know that
before my back took a turn for the worst
it had already been bothered me a little
bit but then it's gotten a lot worse in
college but I think that jump for me
from high school NBA would have been
we've been pretty smooth come over
what did teams ask you why were teams
scared off honestly the teams at the
very top suggest a before Jaffa told me
you know if I'm from there you know
they're taking me so and I had a little
hip that little hip strains and I think
just on top of you know the back stuff
the history of my back that kind of
scared teams a little bit and then you
know once one team gets scared
they all talk so then they all kind of
get scared and I understand it because
it seems the very type of Jeff just want
to make the safe choice and there was a
lot of great players in the dress so you
know I don't have the I don't hold any
grudges or anything where did you think
you were going I know you're happy in
Denver but if I would have talked to you
prior to the draft and I'm there with
your family you would have said this is
the best guest of where I'm going these
this team showed the most interest um
before I would say Sacramento at two
you know we had talked a lot of day they
loved me and they got a great deal for
me and kind of told me that I was their
guy but you know after that that that
hip injury I literally had no idea I
thought maybe Cleveland and ate Chicago
at seven I had no idea I'd heard Dallas
may be a five I knew LA wasn't taking me
but um yeah there was there was a bunch
of chance it was kind of scary
well the hip thing though if that
doesn't happen Michael do you think that
you know because that was your second
day of workouts and you weren't able to
work out because you you had a hip
injury and do you get that feeling that
if that didn't happen if you had been
able to work out then things would have
been different
oh yeah no doubt like I said I would
have been terrified no doubt it was you
know things were trying to trade into
the top five jab me before that happened
and so it kind of it was unfortunate at
the same time I've been working out for
a month straight and so the timing was
so bad that happens almost makes me feel
like I know it was a blessing of God
because he didn't want me to go to all
those teams with at the front of the
jacket maybe wasn't the right situation
for me and I'm
thrive better in this situation we'll
see but that's the way I choose to look
at it because I don't like to do all the
negatives you know he's Michael Porter
Jr the Nuggets forward former Missouri
star joining us Dan Patrick show
favorite player growing up was for sure
Kobe I loved his mentality have you met
him no I actually haven't
I need to sell enough you know idolize
was all about watches his documentary
watch these interviews and I was really
like his his Drive and his uh what he
appreciates the game of basketball but
who do you play like I would say I play
when I when I look at film of players I
would say my game resembles the most
Tracy McGrady you know I still got a lot
of steps to be at that level he's one of
my favorite players won best players of
all time but just the way that he
elevates on a shot can get to a shot
whenever he wants can score on all three
levels could handle I feel like I
resemble them a lot when's the first
time you beat your dad one-on-one oh
that's a good question I can't even
remember he would be he beat me for so
long but even when I said have been
eating him 21-0 he was still somehow
beat me I would say was Crowley's shoes
great to like it might have been sixth
grade so I could beat him
okay well that's still pretty early cuz
your dad played in college right now you
did but my dad yeah yeah I mean he
played in college he could pursue but
you know my sixth grade ask you to
Bambino
I shouldn't be in my life fourth grade
when's the first time you dunked yeah
sixth grade it was no way it was no I
was seventh grade seventh grade summer
going to eighth grade that's when I got
my first dog anybody around him
witnessing yeah my brothers we would all
be outside I mean I was one of those
kids that would not stop trying to dunk
until I could dance like I would always
lower the rim to life and not at first
was like 19
I could get it done on there and then it
was not quite five and finally ten and
that's kind of how I learned how to do
all the tricks like dunking like Rome to
the leg by my back all that stuff just
growing up I would always practice on a
way lower hoop so I always encourage my
little brothers you know if you can't
dunk on a ten yet bounce on the lower
hoops you can you can learn how to do
not I mean I'm still doing that Michael
even at my age I mean I'm still lowering
it down but I have to keep lowering it
I'm not raising it so it's down to about
seven feet now but I'm I'm really I'm
done tearing it up a little bit a deuce
key I hope you're probably not allowed
to ski right before okay don't start
don't start because yeah let's not with
your back in your hip let's let's don't
do that but even though you're in Denver
let's let's not do that the guy do you
want a piece of like a guy you can't
wait to face in the NBA s whoo LeBron
James
I can't wait to uh no boy it's like the
very best player NBA you know that's my
I just want to test myself against them
I'm not really one to back down from
anybody I just want to I want to I want
to be a problem I want to be a problem
for him like go at him and and do what I
can do and just test myself against a
very bad that sounds like something Kobe
would say Michael and like I said that's
my favorite player hey congrats and
hopefully it works out for you and
Denver maybe got the steal in the draft
but hopefully you stay healthy and we
get a chance to see you this upcoming
season appreciate you guys coming on the
show that's a Michael Porter Jr Nuggets
forward former Missouri star for more
Dan Patrick show to the audience Channel
239 on DirecTV or download the Dan
Patrick show app
you